wie entsorgt man eigentlich Frittierfett
Frittierfett müsste gar nicht sofort
entsorgen ihr könnt es bis zu zehnmal
wieder verwenden also erstmal erkalten
lassen und dann nehmt euch ein Trichter
und füllt es einfach zurück in die
Flasche mein frittierte ist jetzt sauber
es kann aber auch sein dass Frittierfett
einfach mal dreckig wird dann müsst ihr
die Reste unten einfach rausfiltern das
würde man dann einfach mit so einem
feinen haarig machen ich sage NEIN zu
Frittierfett im Ausgang
Frittierfett niemals in den Ausfluss es
wird euch verstopfen dann kriegt ihr
richtig Ärger einfach weg ihr könnt
erstmal was Süßes und später was
herzhaftes und dann Fisch frittieren und
dann wieder Fleisch es nimmt nicht den
Geruch an von dem was sie frittiert